une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre présenté par kiss me le
podcast on parle ce qu on veut que nos
invités date seach ph quand tu es avec
moi d'une plante cette semaine c'est la
blague quick et le black friday chez 15
millions des promotions coleman scène
lyon le black durant la black oui de ses
20% de rabais plus des arbres de planter
à chaque pièce vendue le black friday
25% plus des arbres plantés le week-end
le sable monde des 20% des arbres allez
voir ce lyon plus de ceux qui ont des
centaines de suite c'est l'europe qui
ont des caisses pour les airs potes qui
ont des comptes chez elle pour vos ordis
ont tout le stock plein de rabais des
design incroyable on est vraiment
content de travailler encore et smith
sont sont incroyables allez voir ce
qu'on va encourager les jeunes
compagnies d'ici en beauce ont cédé
admis en plus fait qu'aller voir
cependant un code promo en plus je sais
pas s'il s'applique à toutes les pluies
promo déjà mais csf 15 pour cent de
rabais sur tous les étuis tous les
caisses tous les excès de clis me fait
aller bourse cette semaine belgique
cette semaine on reçoit kim klavel sur
le podcast que vous connaissez sans
doute on l'a vu à la télévision avec
brodeur et c'est une des meilleures
boxeuses dans ce cas décrits au monde et
on ne parle de ce monde-là de la boxe
qui est en montre que moi j'ai
personnellement je connais plus non j'ai
vraiment beaucoup appris à savoir
c'est quoi ça se parle depuis que c'est
quoi la beauté finalement de ce sport là
j'ai vraiment mieux compris en fait de
la beauté de ce sport le puits son
régime d'entraînement sonne vraiment
parler en détail de ckoi sa routine
c'est quoi son c'est quoi sa vie femmes
à kim klavel pour se préparer pour des
cons beauce important d'un combat qui
semble très bien tout combat de
championnat du monde justement alors
peut-être dans quelques semaines et leur
la ceinture le champion du monde alors
c'est très excitant c'est pas qu'ils
allaient apprécier conversation qu'ils
aiment c'est une personne avec une joie
de vivre et une énergie contagieuse
c'est vraiment super le fun et espère
belle réponse alors grand plaisir de
leurs résultats avec les athlètes on s'y
reconnaît beaucoup fait que vous allez
on espère que vous allez aimer la
conversation juste avant on va remercier
nos commanditaires hung le podcast de
cette semaine et présenté par même skate
qui viennent de sortir
écoutez moi bien
un shampoing et revitalisant deux en
deux ans non et un body wash pour la
douche avec leurs fragrances ya de sûr
signature de m'indiquer la fréquence je
vous parle souvent avec le parfum monde
comment on comme un compliment souvent
sur mon mot d'or grâce aux parfums skype
qui le met cheveux sens mon corps quand
chardat deux sens évidemment ils ont
aussi leurs pleurs perfect package 4.0
dame madame parfaite package 4 points il
est ce qu'ils avaient besoin il arrive
loin pour être heureux dans ce magazine
poste achètent ce qu'ils loupent cécile
meyer qui ad'autres les pas de sens et
remplit de bonheur avec les fans qui
s'en viennent pour faire un don à
un proche qui comme vous aimez rien de
mieux qu'un bon même skype on se fait
beaucoup parler des bleus on a le plus
parlé moins d'ego ça parle de cet
étrange inconnu pas mal du podcast mais
parce que vous vous aimez si vous en
achetez parce qu'on aurait pu cette pub
le silmo m'acheter pas l'épreuve du
mannequin et on reçoit que des gamins on
y croit on les utilise donc on pourrait
pas être plus fier de représenter même
skype alors on va continuer d'en parler
davantage des couilles mais c'est propre
c'est pas juste d'acheter 10 maintenant
les shampoings maintenant toutes sortes
de produits pour hommes pour pour le
corps pour faux c'est vraiment une
expérience complètement du script donc
ça ça vaut la peine on a un code promo
pour vous pour 20% de rabais plus la
livraison gratuite donc c'est énorme le
code promo c'est sans filtre en un mot
sur deux là dessus merci m'indiquer où
le podcast est présenté par auch lag et
le temps des fêtes s'en vient il
critiquant des fêtes dit si jean soirée
qui viennent chez nous à l'hibiscus qui
nous donne cette impression là c'était
réconfort de cette chaleur le du temps
des fêtes en outre
depuis 2008 en fait bien sur les
tablettes de la saq il se distingue par
sa couleur rose et ses petites touches
de pamplemousse qui vient de saint jean
c'est au goût du biscuit
embauche c'est une symphonie de saveurs
florales vous pouvez l'utiliser en jeans
tonique veulent utiliser tel quel
honnêtement nous tiens hochelaga panique
c'est le fournisseur officiel d'alcool
du studio sf on a eu quelques petites
soirées
jean aux ragots nettement c'est
absolument incroyable
peu importe la façon de laquelle vous
voulez le consommer sauter là dessus
avec les fat 10 ans viennent toutes les
occasions sont bonnes pour goûter aux
jeans à l'hibiscus d'hochelaga
évidemment à toutes les autres produits
flag qui sont encore une fois le
fournisseur officiel du studio sf ça ça
veut dire que si vous voulez louer
studio venu ici il avait axé notre
région est rempli de produits h line
vous avez accès aux jeans hibiscus
incroyable quand on prépare pour les
fêtes on a soutenu cadeau pour rempli
notre banc de touche la gale hibiscus
serai pas déçu pour savoir bien souvent
sans les tester merci aux flammes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais tu y as merci d'être là et ça me
fait plaisir je présente aussi est
sculpté dans font aujourd'hui des termes
deux entraînements je comprends bien
ouais mais donc ma vie rocher un petit
peu matin j'avais un entraînement à 9
heures je finis comme à 10h15 le g20 est
ici pour 10h 45 secondes après ma coach
m'a amené mon lunch et la veine une
journée pédagogique elle est enseignante
à l'oeil ou gaulle je mangeais sept ans
le taux de change mais c'est une couette
pile je suis avec vous
vraiment oui j'ai l'entraînement deux
heures à 14 heures place mars parce que
j'ai eu super un banquier c'est le
panthéon ans kool shen bouteille a été
inaugurée puis on est à éviter
à sa table c'est vraiment une journée
journée
j'imagine qu'elle tournait court terme
d'entraînement sur samba sow tout le
temps si oui vraiment et surtout que le
je vais boxer le 17 décembre géant plein
sens de mon camp d'entraînement avec ses
deux entraînements par jour du lundi au
samedi
puis c'est ma psy et c'est important
ouais ouais là si je me rappelles tu es
comme on parle un peu avant le fait de
la natation longtemps puis la sieste
entre les dents les doubles crypte
vie tourne autour de 7,6 planifient des
informations des choix sont en fonction
de dassier et du cabba tous deux jugent
faire parce que moche et qu'ils me
disaient faire une heure et demie maxime
et encadrants parce que sinon flybe je
trouve être encore pire qu'avant te
coucher tôt de tout cas offert cette
fête une heure et demie c'est quoi ton
gsm à 1h30 2h maximum du package mais
comme un maximum est mon cas drame et on
se marie à merveille hammam et sert à
sécheval jeu dans deux heures que je
prédomine encore plus je pense je suis
quelqu'un que j'ai besoin des 12 13
heures par jour je dors tu dors mettons
un diseur aussi le nuit là oh et puis
plus plus j'apprends je mon combat plus
je dors je pense que la semaine avant je
peux dormir 16 ans par jed dans 101
legault alex avril qui dit qu'il dormait
comme
15,9 à
la boxe ça m'a toujours fasciné par ce
que il ya vraiment il ya vraiment des
cycles oui puis il faut il faut que
j'imagine que tu regardes de trouver une
balance à travers tous ces six clubs
parce que là en ce moment je me gêne que
tout ce que tu serais c'est vraiment
ultra calcul et le comment on vient de
parler au niveau de ton horaire mais
j'imagine que la nutrition j'imagine
qu'il est bien le sommeil les les
entraînements précis j'imagine que le
laos le manteau aucune marge de
manoeuvre sur rien tout seul non
vraiment et puis autant qu'elle la boxe
est tellement c'est un sport individuel
dans le ring oui tu es tout seul à
performer mais j'ai tellement un équipe
autour de moitié comme tu dis je te mets
nutritionnelle et mon préparateur
physique j'ai ma coach stéphane à rochus
6 kg et qui travaille en tant que coach
aussi
ces psychologues sportifs ya tellement
de trucs auto qui t'amène à performer le
jour j c'est vraiment on
va travailler tes des fois c'est plus
musculation plus endurance musculaire
plus de charge plus de plus de rendre à
la botte tranquillement qu'on va
approcher du combo ça diminue que l'on
va on va sentir qu'on l'à beaucoup
d'énergie pour avoir le pic là le jour
beauté
puis l'unc à l'entraînement quand tu
sais mettons que tu un combat qui arrive
à telle date le camp d'entraînement
combien de semaines c'est l'idéal c'est
un huitième but selon lui c'est vraiment
eu le temps d'aller faire tout ce que
nous avons une bonne préparation puis
aussi c'est moi je suis quelqu'un quand
mes combats je suis pas quelqu'un qui
prend énormément de poids aussi beaucoup
de boxeurs des fouilles vont se laisser
aller en deux combats et qu'ils vont
faire la fête on mangeait beaucoup mais
j'essaie d'avoir un bon mode de vie à
l'année longue je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on peut atteindre les plus hauts
sommets parce que tu es si tu
t'entraînes juste quand un combo je
trouve cette mentalité à ce qui n'est
pas la mienne tout fou donc j'ai demandé
de condamner combat ça remonte à quand
où et les 28 ou au stade j attendrai
halles puis en moyenne dans le fond une
boxeuse comme toi ça fait combien de
combos non mais environ
quatre combats par année la salle avait
été difficile à cause de la pandémie
mais quand même j'avais eu la chance
d'aller boxer à las vegas au mexique mon
promoteur yvon michel il ya quand même
biais arranger ma carrière environ 1 4 5
qu'on va parrainer j'ai fait plus que ça
serait ça serait ce parce que c'est
souvent ça va être en début de carrière
tu vas faire plus de combos je pense
qu'à un moment donné j'ai déjà fait ici
cette combine une année mais tu suives a
cédé quatre hommes et le jeu fait dévier
ce qu'on dit c'est pas pareil et tandis
que quand tu boxes un quatre hommes
tuent pour boxer le mode après il n'y a
pas de problème
meetic en fin décembre si c'est
physiquement très difficile ça va
dépendre aussi de tes combats si c'était
un combo qui est très très difficile qui
étoffe des besoins de la récupération en
beauté après avant de recommencer un
camp d'entraînement parce que ça va
vraiment dépendre
c'est vraiment du cas par cas bien entre
l'excès camp d'entraînement l'autre dit
cet égard d un un régime de vie sain
c'est quoi dessus au niveau de
l'entraînement pendant ces périodes là
têtus plus est ce que tu fais plus du
cross training ou peinture aux rameurs
focus bottes je fais beaucoup de
généralistes uva mettons la boxe cas
qu'on est en camp d'entraînement on en
fait tellement et après on a besoin
vraiment d'une transition qu'on va faire
peut-être une journée de boxe par
semaine ou deux journées de boxe
tellement que ça tu manques qui casse
tout va recommencer ton 4ème acteur fin
de ordre de reprendre ne frapper dans un
sac si c'est vraiment c'est comme une
drogue la mefa qu'on diminue beaucoup au
niveau de la boxe puis après ça on va
faire plus de la préparation physique
c'est la course la musculation aller
travailler des choses qu'on n'a pas tout
le temps le teinter des petits détails
comment garder une forme générale
endurance doit bondir onze de base
exactement puis quand qu'on va
recommencer quand l'entraînement l'on va
réinsérer la boxe gratuit vainement vite
or devant jim de boxe de caen a fait
deux trois semaines qu'on ne peut pas
frapper dans un sac le
dauphin
enfin le le sparring fait genre c'est le
tuer des combes ordres d'un entraînement
sur ça représente quel pourcentage de
titres reading pendant quarante
remontant dans le camp d'entraînement je
vais essayer de faire deux sparring par
semaine puis on va y aller graduellement
exemple que le je m'entraîne pour un
indice rares métiers les premières
semaines on va faire juste deux fois
cinq ans ensuite loupé deux fois 6 2 x
huit on va faire un disque rendre
peut-être juste une fois dans un
calendrier pour aller voir ok c'est
sainté ce cross
d'énergie je suis bien mais t'as pas
besoin de faire cesser c'est une vieille
mentalité de dire qui s'apprend des
sparrings difficile faut-il faire juste
des dix rendre ce c'est pas vrai c'est
pourquoi les smagghe année ça reste que
la boxe et des coupes pour la tête
effectivement on veut être vraiment
frais dispos rendu à notre combat qu'on
va faire des combos des sparrings pas
toujours difficile défendre de besoin un
combat avec une fille qui qui plus
novices exemple mais que moi je vais
pratiquer juste ma défensive qu'elle a
pu me frapper comme elle veut mais moi
je m'implique juste ma défensive bleue
kilic points passés en dessous ça soit
facile parce qu'on apprend beaucoup dans
la dans la facilité tout le temps de
voir ce qui se passe 2 le temps de
réfléchir tota de bouger mais de besoin
aussi des combos des sparrings difficile
parce que cela c'est sûr que le combat
va être difficile mais quand eux réussi
à le faire tranquillement avec une fille
qui a moins d'expérience ça devient
acquis puis le quand tu deviens avec une
fille qui est meilleur c'est acquis
pilote super forme ce qui est une des
meilleures au monde dans le fond
contredite par une difficile contre qui
tu veux leur faire ni des filles du
mexique dont venir ici au québec pour
m'aider puis j'ai la chance et je
m'entraîne au club de boxe morel au
centre claude-robillard puis à des
filles sont championnes canadiennes au
niveau amateur de ces défis qui me donne
vraiment un bon challenge puis je tout
le temps la plus petite je suis pas très
pesant je suis une mouche même pas une
mouche au complet
d'activités souvent sont plus présentes
puis vont ils vont servir de leur
physique pour me faire travailler fait
que même si peut-être techniquement
n'est pas son - et ont moins
d'expérience mais physiquement ça va
compenser les cats dit champion du monde
amateur c'est qu'aulas c'est quoi la
différence entre la boxe amateur la boxe
professionnelle puis est-ce que ce qu'on
pense que la boxe professionnelle on la
voit le tir puisque la boxe amateur
c'est ce qu'on voit oui exactement
c'est tellement un monde différent j'ai
boxé ça fait 15 ans que je boxe
maintenant puis j'étais certain sur
l'équipe nationale avant de passer
professionnel lutte et la boxe amateur
c'est on en entend pas tant parler de
ces mêmes cpo médiatisé tant que ça mais
c'est tellement bossé technique la
différence c'est qu'on ne les chez les
femmes ont un casque nos gars et des dix
ans chez les professionnels c'est dès 8
ans des plus petits guerre puis on n'a
pas de casques depuis dans la boxe
amateur on va pas seulement trois rounds
de trois minutes
c'est comme plus un sprint on peut dire
c'est plus de la touche sur un peu de
l'escrim un peu plus comme des scripts
et à moins de chance de blessés on peut
dire
mais vraiment c'est beaucoup plus rare
parce que c'est des tournois ont été
tués dans un tournoi est un tirage au
sort va avoir 25 pays qui participent à
ce tournoi là hop tu vas commencer tu
boxes contre les états unis si tu gagnes
ensuite va passer contre le nicaragua
tisser comme c'est pas contre qui tu
veux boxer fait que c'est toujours une
surprise tu es toujours prêt peut faire
trois quatre combats dans une semaine
mais puis tu dois faire le point aussi à
chaque matin c'est comme nous en boxe
professionnelle ont nommé examen
exactement je boxe à 108 livre j'ai une
poésie 24 heures maman combo je mangeais
mairie drap puis je vais boxer mais
tandis qu'à amateurs exemple moi je boxe
et à sang si ce livre mais je devais
refaire 106 livres 3 4 fois dans la même
service que
certains pour qui en 10 mai
c'est quand même story drapeau temps de
manger autant factice et c'est quand
même ces deux mondes complètement
différents mais ces deux mondes assez
difficile et puis ou excuse puis au
moment où ce qui se décide de switcher
j'imagine que comme ces différentes on
ta préparation est différente
l'instinct adaptation
la défensive va être très importante
c'est le style professionnels le style
amateur est vraiment différent même des
fois je mets les gants je fais du
sparring avec des filles qui ont un
style typique amateur puis ça me donne
du troublant c'est vraiment un sprint
est une énorme tu te touche ma voix je
me tendit professionnelle des plus
grandes des était coincé des coups de
poing pour faire mal c'est plaisant
c'est de la qualité de points tandis
qu'en boxe amateur tu vas - d'attardés à
la qualité de coups de poing ça va plus
ça les touche et vite faire des points
dominés laurent ont été déplacées et
c'est vraiment différent de la boxe
professionnelle tout qu'est ce qui t'a
donné envie de faire ce switch le j'ai
toujours voulu boxer professionnel je me
rappelle quand j'étais jeune j'ai
commencé j'avais 15 ans puis dans ce
temps là c'était vraiment les bonnes
années à lucian bute et puis j'allais au
centre bell c'est le premier combo
j'avais vu ça m'avait comme tellement
donné des frissons j'ai imaginé un jour
je pourrais peut-être boxe au centre
bell mais je me dis c'était possible je
voyais pas de femmes tant que ceux ci
s'étaient pas mediative le 15 ans et
j'en voyais pas boxé au centre bell je
me dis je rêve mais c'est comme c'est
pas possible
mais aujourd'hui le 17 décembre je boxe
au centre de réalité ça veut devenir une
réalité mais gérard style qui
ressemblait plus aux professionnels
qu'aux amateurs seuls les entraîneurs me
disait avec l'adaptation la transition
pour moi c'est fait vraiment un
rapidement puis j'ai eu la chance de
m'accomplir vraiment chez les amateurs
de faire toutes les tournois possibles
les femmes ont été acceptées jusqu en
2012 aux jeux olympiques oubliez juste
trois catégories pose sur dix dont la
mienne était pas le tua que j'ai décidé
de c'est de pas perdre mon temps d'aller
tout de suite chez les professionnels
j'avais tout fait des tournois que je
pouvais puis j'avais déjà un bon bagage
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des promoteurs
qui étaient intéressés à mme signé la
boxe professionnelle s'en prendre sans
promoteur c'est vraiment ici est ce que
la plupart des meilleurs amateurs font
le switch voie professionnelle ou saponé
samara pas nécessairement comme les
cubains ont pas le droit de boxe
professionnelle vieux cec les champions
c'est les meilleurs boxeurs au monde
sait les plus médaillés aux jeux
olympiques dans les tournois
international ue - droit n'ont pas le
droit le pays n'accepte pas qu'ils
gagnent leur vie en boxant ses effectifs
pour ça qu'on voit souvent les cubains
qui vont déménager ou se trouvait aux
états unis pour pouvoir continuer une
carrière professionnelle
c'est france ouai souvent les femmes ou
s'ils étaient avant c'était moins
populaire la boxe professionnelle chez
les femmes le ça commence avec de plus
en plus de femmes qui il décide d'aller
boxer professionnelle mais en beaucoup
le qui vont faire une super belle
carrière devant elle ou jeux olympiques
qui vont terminer en boxe amateur en a
que la boxe professionnelle ça ça les
effraie un peu où ça les intéresse moins
c'est bien correct ici c'est vraiment
gros côté business dans la boxe
professionnelle qui est pas en boxe
amateur qu'est ce qui explique
l'histoire quand même
quand même prestigieuse du québec dans
la boxe professionnelle si on eu des
bons d excellents boxeurs tu parles de
leshan victimes je me rappelle
précisément
sa première défaite en fait le jeu me
rappelle flotte je me rappelle le
feeling que j'avais dans le ventre
qu'accueillir command queuing qui a
commencé à
montrer qu'ils qui avec ses jambes lors
chez picquier commencé à être bien car
je me rappelle le feeling que j'avais
toujours mais moins de vouloir mourir
puis
puis me rappelle exactement jeter ou en
fait puis qu'est ce qui explique qu'au
québec on a
un bel historique comme ceux de boxeur
mais on a eu ces les anciens je sais
qu'il ya eu les hilton dans le temps
qu'ils étaient super populaire elle
tient goûter éric lucas stéphane ouellet
puis on voudrait on a eu un gros aille
je trouve de la boxe professionnelle
qu'on vendait des billets je pense que
c'est un peu du à au charme au charisme
et la gentillesse les
lucia bosé d'éric lucas et ensuite on
sait qu'on a eu un gros crash comme
la mise en vente des billets on ne les
menace identifiée un champion au québec
et on a eu jean pascal aussi puis déjà
peu importe ce qui est arrivé
dernièrement et tout il y en a fait pour
la boxe c'est un vrai champion jamais
dit non à aucun des filles puissent
vraiment un coeur de guerriers mais je
pense qu'on a des des entraîneurs
compétents justement comme stéphane
larouche qui est très très très
compétent que c'était un artiste de la
boxe on ne marquera musée aussi qui est
un très bon coach puis en vrai qu'à part
eux
ils commencent à voir le de la relève
des nouveaux entraîneurs qui sont
motivés et qui veulent apprendre fait
que je pense qu'on une nouvelle relève
deux boxeurs qui s'en viennent dans les
prochaines années
mais le québec je pense que si c'est une
question de promoteurs tentent avec le
promoteur qui est décédé voyons comment
qui s'appelait
il dit chrome os
le quelques mois il y faisait beaucoup
des combos locaux terrain québécois
contre un autre québécois hilton où elle
est et si je pense que ce les gens se
sont vraiment approprié et la boxe de
cette façon là parce que maintenant les
promoteurs vont beaucoup signé exemple
un russe on est quelqu'un qui vient
d'ailleurs on va contrer que les
québécois ont de la misère à
s'identifier à ces athlètes le
ça fait du sens puis est ce que toi
qu'en grande synthe toujours intéressé
la boxe de toujours regarder ça tout le
temps oui j'ai tout le temps à regarder
ça ça me passionne c'est quelque chose
que je peux pas expliquer ces bizarres
et me la boxe cessé mais c'est dans mes
tripes cj leur sac puis je peux pas le
dire en mots pourquoi ça me fait du bien
puis quand je suis dans milk ont dans
mes entraînements je suis tellement
balancé dans ma vie aussi pis quand je
suis en deux combats je me cherche
andres j'aime bien tout débat lancé
c'est comme si l'entraînement m'apporte
genre
du bien-être dans ma vie je me sens bien
dans ma tête
mon après-carrière me fait vraiment
parle de savoir je veux être qui mois
après avoir été cet athlète le commun
que je vais être fier de moi que ce
geste parce que j'ai pensé à ce sommet
ça sent visé le commando armé le succès
c'est le côté stressant c'est quelque
chose que tu as haget entrevoit dans
laquelle genre de futurs sa maîtresse de
cette retraite le site you mais le
j'essaye de vie vraiment me moment
présent parce que
de boxe
l'athlète s'est piqué quand ça passe je
veux pas me dire j'ai donc du rif déjà
ses débuts à 100% c'est pour ça que je
déménage à montréal que je viens de
joliette et j'ai lâché l'hôpital je veux
vivre mais en faire à 100% j'ai j'habite
dans mon petit trot et demi toutes mes
amies sont toutes à joliette je vois pas
beaucoup ma famille je vois pas beaucoup
mes amis j'ai pris beaucoup de décisions
un pour ma box puis c'est des fous je
regarde mes amis qui ont 30 un tj non
une maison ayant deux enfants combien
ont le même
ils ont un job très stable et comme je
sens brest son art en août et puis je me
dis non dans son jeu physique et gmp
toutes ces affaires là qui vient
d'énumérer le que ce soit maison famille
et enfin chiens sont déjà fort que tu
peux avoir
tout le temps dans ta vie le reste de ta
vie tandis qu'elle est une boxeuse parmi
les meilleurs au monde qui fait
seulement soupe qui d'eps apple et les
plus hauts sommets de sa propre de sa
propre montagne bien que c'est ce que tu
peux pas le faire à l'infini n'ont cessé
depuis quand ça va finir mais
probablement que tu vas faire comme moi
tu veux te met à courir des marathons
parce qu'il faut que je fasse du sport
tout le temps est
ce que est ce que la boxe peut aussi
devenir un genre de
[Musique]
parce qu'on sentait quand même un sport
qui est dangereux parce que le bus ici
c'est de nok et l'autre personne mais
est-ce que la boxe peut aussi devenir un
support juste de
fitness fille de dee de santé juste
entraîné depuis
puisque ce soit sur un punching bag ou
en sparring j'imagine que des façons de
faire pour qu'il y avait la mine il
dangereux
puis c'est drôle parce qu'ils veulent
deux semaines marc berard s'est inscrit
à la base à one way c'est vraiment drôle
atl adore ça me fait donc du bien puis à
frappe dans un sac puis à fait il est
temps que le coach et limoges a fait ce
puits ci-après nom qui fait ça de
manière récréative puis c'est pas parce
que c'est mon sport mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est un des sports les
plus complets et autant abdominale les
jambes c'est solliciter les brûleurs
diot les cardio le psychologique et
quand tu travailles dans un ré même
c'est pas te battre avec quelqu'un
frapper dans des ieg a frappé sur un sac
si ça défoule c'est comme un thérapie
stockons devrait mettre son nom dans les
écoles et cdd punching bag ton petit
groupe et rotana audio de l'envoyer
oui mais on voit les noms frappé dans un
sac ça fait du bien il est à fond
si je donnais des cours de boxe un
moment donné à l'école secondaire saint
roch de l'achigan c'est vraiment tout d
un groupe à problèmes qui avaient des
problèmes de comportement j'avais en
début d'année j'avais un petit goût qui
il y avait les cheveux longs y'avait pas
d'amis et is camouflé derrière ses
cheveux il s'habillait en grand parce
qu'il n'était pas fier de lui puis
tranquillement juste à boxer puisse
dettes et je faisais beaucoup de positif
avec les mondes août et dont berne a du
bon m onde de choc dont d'un fort
dispositif
est tu t'améliores à chaque fois que je
lui disais puis à la fin de l'année
celui qui a gagné le certificat de la
personne qui s'est le plus amélioré
autant l'école dans toutes les sphères
de sa vie et avait les cheveux il sait
tout faire une belle coupe de cheveux il
y avait perdu du poids il y avait des
amis et ça lui a pris confiance en lui
ça l'a fait sortir de sa queue puis si
la boxe a pas porté sa des jeunes mais
c'est mission accomplie
un beau sport comme un complet carney le
titre des enfants aussi j'imagine true
blue aurait quelque chose si ça permet
de canaliser cette énergie là mais
quelque chose de
2,2 de positifs les grecs sinon je vous
avais déjà rentré dans un gymnase de
boxe une fois dans votre vie jamais mon
nom quand se rendent dans un gym de boxe
à première vue je trouve que c'est
intimidant comme moi c'est l'effet que
ça m'avait fait quand j'avais 15 ans
tentant de bruit des ballons toute la
cloche
c'est vraiment intimidant et au petit
installe devant ton miroir tu apprends
la base de la boxe sur garde auto puis
personne ce manque de respect comme une
loi non écrite dans les gymnases d'arts
martiaux et que tout le monde est
respectueux tout le monde sentait que tu
vois un homme une femme vieux une jeune
n'importe qui un petit goût nous qui
s'entraînent dans notre gymnase de boxe
ea otis puis tout le monde là est tout
le monde tout le monde f1 avec tout le
monde peu importe de quelle religion tu
es l'ethnicité c'est ce qui est beau
c'est vraiment l espèce de la mentalité
derrière les arts martiaux je trouve ça
un peu de karaté quand j'étais plus
jeune je t'aimais mais juste l'idée que
j'en vois pas ce que ça m'intéresse
beaucoup j'écoutais j'écoute les lie au
f si j'écoute la boxe ça m'intéresse ces
choses là puis la mentalité derrière
maintenant le trash toc j'aï seul truc
c'est de la merde c'est un show business
pour ce qui m'intéresse mais la
mentalité des camps du respect pour
l'art martial comme tel puis des grands
maîtres puis de tout ce château c'est
vraiment c'est beau ça fait genre une
unité pissas les valeurs qui sont
véhiculées par ce sont au contraire sont
pas celles de jean ray combo qui violent
le contraire est vraiment pop i télé les
athlètes en général qui performent
vraiment dans les arts martiaux où la
boxe n'est pas de quoi souvent j'ai
remarqué c'est vraiment pas des gens qui
sont agressifs dans la vie de tous les
jours s'ils sont mêmes usines sises
honte et mettons du regard georges st
pierre s'est entraîné un moment donné à
notre gymnase puis travaillant je pense
c'est un des athlètes qui travaillent en
y tourner aucun coins ronds et mais dans
la vie de tous les jours guy gentlemen
ce goal com bien sympathique lucia 0
agressivité ce gros mot dans la vie et
j'ai travaillé avec des bébés naissant
des petits ponts à l'hôpital de gm ou
naissance puis je plan fiches
thématiques ci comme ça par rapport leur
besoin d'être quelqu'un d'agressif puis
de frustrés de la vie pour pouvoir
performer dans la boxe c'est vraiment je
trouve tellement que c'est cela bautista
un sport c'est un enjeu d'un respect
mutuel entre les deux athlètes puis oui
ça reste que c'est il ya des
conséquences comme dans tous les sports
tous jouent au football les risques de
commotions roquettes et les goys arrive
des accidents formule 1 tam et anton et
on peut bien explosé puis c'est la même
chose à la boxe mais reçu qu on met trop
la phase de l'étude deux fois qu'on
parle de la boxe je trouve que oui mais
en même temps c'est normal parce que les
gens qui me connaissent pas la boxe qui
en ont jamais fait c'est ce qu'on voit
c'est ce qui montre à la télévision puis
c'est il voit pas toutes les billes de
signes ne t'y tout qu'est ce qui se
passe à l'entraînement commun que
l'athlète a monté comme un qui était
arrivé pour écrire pour arriver là si
oui un combat c'est 10 points la tête
mais
c'est pour de vrai c'est fait dans le
respect c'est bizarre à dire mais ces
deux personnes consentantes qui sont le
tai chi deux personnes qui se sont
entraînés pour être là aussi pillent des
règlements et thé la régie des sports et
les juges qui sont l'oeil les rêves qui
sont le chemin pour nous protéger les
deux va avoir passé des radios au niveau
du cerveau si tout est beau il ya des
midis côté pour savoir si les deux
personnes sont vraiment en bonne santé
pour pouvoir faire ce sport le factice
est très surveillée puis si les jeunes
décidé d'abolir la boxe mais le monde le
ferait mais au noir comme en cachette
canton d'audenge et combattu et qu'on
voit exactement acté c'est aussi parce
qu'ils ont le sport mais ce sera une
question parce que je n'ai pas d'opinion
là dessus mais est ce que nous permet
trop d'enfants d'enfer sur le knockout
champix sûr parce que je parle que du
point de vue du public en lock out a
impressionné est-ce que ce qu'est ce que
tu sens que c'est encourager qui
incombent aux finissants dans le cas où
tous pas nécessaire moi mettons je pense
que oui quand-même basque et si ça
serait mentir de dire le contraire
puis 600 recule le 100 m le 200 av le
300 av le milan la bataille fait partie
de notre adn dans la trêve le dos des
grecs
et comme balmont par milliers ça
causerait quel être humain et comme il
ya une curiosité
et je connais quelqu'un faisait des
combos de beto tech des poissons
comme tout le monde dès qu'ils peuvent
ils font des compos combats de coqs
combats de chiens combattent bête au
combat de d'humains des smoothies et
toutes sortes de sorte de combos mais
d'où ça vient ça ça doit être dans notre
adn de 18 ans avant jésus-christ où
c'est par lettre aux deux camps même
primal il est question d'un kit au fond
deux autres parce que c'est vrai que il
ya quand même une curiosité
de voir m mettons de ses forces et des
fois sortie des bars les jardins qui se
battent et piwi c'est comme tu veux pas
nécessairement le voir mais en même
temps tu peux pas vraiment regarder
ailleurs c'est comme tu regarde
comme un peu de plaisir quand même avoir
un fax il faut parer on est comme un
voyeur un peu puis si c'est juste
qu'avec le tas ben c'est plus des
combats de gladiateurs qu'on se perdre
avec des épées way s'est faite sous des
règlements ouais
des tests médicaux pour savoir sont en
bonne position pour le faire de
l'entraînement et s'est rendu très très
technologique le les entraînements aussi
fax et je pense que c'est bien fait puis
comprend jamais abolir les batailles que
c'est dé la boxe et du respect c'est de
l'or complètement toi j'imagine que tu
es capable de voir de voir au delà du
lock-out moi je me rappelle bien je
regarde dans le prime de floyd
mayweather loup est ce qu'il va être
musicien battre contre les meilleurs pis
il y avait pas de nos cadres qui se
faisaient plus le montant est plafonné à
2 pas vrai qu'il est bon plus tu sors
les statistiques de genre les coups que
lui a touché versus les kooks et fait
toucher les fesses à aucun bon certes il
y aurait reçu deux points pendant le
combat complet combat la somme toute
série si tu regardes tu mets ton
petit-frère les personnes qui sont en
cas des personnes qui se blesse mais lui
se fait juste pour toucher ouais puis ça
j'imagine que tout écart est d'apprécier
ce autant qu'un a400m en plus parce que
je pense que les boxeurs on aime
regarder la technique ça c'est sûr et on
va voir les esquives le mouvement de son
pied son épaule commun khemissat mais ça
on va tout regarder les détails
peut-être un peu que monsieur madame
tout le monde qui connaissent un petit
peu moins soeurs vont pas apprécier
parce qu'ils connaissent pas c'est un
peu de l'ignorance
c'est normal pour ce que la catégorie
maître que tout le monde qu'à passer
l'épaule au moins parce que tu sais
jamais un coin une personne ne tombait
pas que c'est ce que les gens aiment
actif c'est drôle parce que les gens
chialent que la boxe il ya des notes
épicées pas bons pneus mais en même
temps c'est ce qui s'appelle savoir si
un repos ils sont pas contents un
effectif de trouver un juste milieu là
dedans puis g2a encore dans ma fiche
puis c'est vraiment bizarre à dire mais
j'ai aimé ce d2 d'abord le fit lors il
bonne décharge d'adrénaline bonne
décharge à dire à l'inpi c'est des coups
de poing qui te prépares tu veux
tellement qu'ils soient de qualité pis
va les nuggets mpoc point catsburg
frapper fort le que tu vois que tu vas
charge et une info qui va ouvrir ta main
trop grand tu vas swing et c'est pas des
swings comme on s'est vraiment un petit
point de qualité très précis puis la
personne poupe alain petit black hole
puis elle serait allée habiter c'est
vraiment le c'est mission accomplie
c'est bizarre à dire mais ça pourrait
m'arriver à moi aussi parce qu'elle
aussi cherche à me faire la même chose
ça doit être j'avais jamais essayé
d'imaginer le feeling de comme que le
coup tu lances notre quelqu'un
d'atypique ce soit juste comme lights
outlet on ferme les
critiques le team usa la tête à certains
accusent même même si tu le fais pas
pour ce nécessairement sur la tête quand
même une for his own site ouais c'est
pas contre l'autre personne c'est lors
de ces jeux nous c'est comme le travail
pour quelque chose puis ça allait
fonctionner c'est tellement d'heures
d'entraînement si un timing parfait dans
ton combat de ton coin d'étranges qui
est avec ton coude avec ton épaule c'est
tout tout ensemble mais jamais au grand
jamais moi ça m'est passé dans la tête
de me dire je veux il fait remarquer je
veux qu'à soi mais jamais jamais jamais
mois après à chacun mais combo je veux
dans le vestiaire et je me sens en
hébreu avec la fille
un premier combat je suis ami avec tout
mes anciens adversaires on se parle
encore je pourrais aller dans le paix
dans leur pays n'importe quel mac
heureux chez elle comme beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de respect et on sait
le dit et après le combat 1 quand me
donner ce point là encore à joly
vraiment sûr c'était vraiment une bonne
défensive si on n'est pas gêné de dire
ce que l'autre fait depuis taxer ceux
qui ces seuls espoirs relatifs à un mois
avant mais compétition souvent il
fallait que je me mette dans un genre de
mindset de genres et de tous
je m'étais jamais d'être métal pitié je
m inquiète vraiment tout c'est quoi ton
27 quand tu rappes aspire plus mosquée
juste être cela mon couloir l'oeil
aperçu je me battrai contre personne
mais je me crée des jeux le prime est
quand même beaucoup toi est-ce que
thuram dans un combat c'est quoi ton ton
rituel ps que tu es ce qu'il faut que tu
ne m en mode
je m'envole bape tout est ici commence
comment tout fonctionne elle a joué
tellement qu est ce qui est drôle si la
veille de mon combat souvent l'état
l'hôtel c'est quand on va ailleurs et
puis nommé entraîneur daniel petit et
fans c'est un cofacteur dorment dans la
même chambre que moi j'ai tout le temps
de la chambre à côté tu qu'on peut
ouvrir la porte lors qu'il est donc une
chambre s'imbriquant puis daniel llc a
dit kim ça se peut qu'elle arrive à 4 5
heures du matin dans notre chambre comme
ceux pour new jersey mais j'ai besoin
d'extérioriser huawei chacune des formes
étranges dans ma chambre puis je suis
capable de dormir je veux ouvrir leurs
portes j'ai regardé le jeu dispute
souvenez inbev et à aulas j'aimerais sur
le compare de la stratégie
la journée avant la journée à 20 peluche
tournage comme
lyon 2e
ah ouais aulas et par tour le jeu n'est
pas confortable pillon drake il me
passait des mauvaises idées mais le ch
correct je vous en parle le peace corps
et que j'ai besoin d'extérioriser et
j'ai dit je regardais par la fenêtre
pilule j'ai vu par j'ai boxé au mgm
grand à
las vegas j'ai dit je regardais par la
fenêtre c'était écrit mgm janvier
potiche ta vegas plus je me suis dit la
plus grosse place au monde mgm j'ai dit
j'ai décidé que pour moi ça s'appelait
mon grand moment c'est pour ça que c'est
mjm c'est mon grand moment je parle
maïwenn moment malgré ceci même en
espagne elle me momen t grande des
lâches et elle marchait dans chambre
puis j'ai joué
j'ai besoin d'extérioriser mais savez
vous quoi c'est quoi ma force moi et me
dit quoi du moins le cèdre en tout cas
c'est inconfortable confortable puis je
marche plus je marque qu'après ce coup
je me suis extérieur des jeux tellement
beige dort comme un bébé les projets
comme une genre de boule dans la gorge
puis faut que l'expriment sinon je peux
bien que son rang des habitués ouais
c'est donc l'abandon ce réveil puis on a
tous rêvé
sonic avec son team qui tourne est
qu'ils aient maïwenn moment
même
[Rires]
et
quand je vais dans mon jeu mais toujours
mais secteur j'ai une toune
fearless que ça s'appelle c'est comme un
petit fait un speech mettons puis une
voix le devient de chercher puis ça
j'écoute ses avants chacun de mes
combats c'est quelque chose qui qui me
mets dans ma bulle dans mon monde pour
drake avec sujet n'est présent je
deviens
cellphone ce feeling un jeu le
la journée à 20 moment même le outils la
semaine avant le
meilleur feeling que je retrouverai
jamais dans ma vie mais ton le camas
télphone comment toutes tes pensées sont
dirigées vers ce clair le matin tu
penses à tue tête tout le temps en train
de revoir les affaires dans ta tête de
voir un million deux scénarios possibles
tous les rimes agite les imagine tous
les imagine tout ça devait lui aussi n'a
pas exactement la même chose si tu
imagines ton combat ta stratégie et tu
te rappelles qu'est ce que
je vais dans le coin rouge je vais
marcher mon entrée ouest comme ceux sur
cette une le je vais faire ça a
tellement menti comme tout se voit tout
dans ta tête même des fois je me ferme
les yeux pis j'essaye d'imaginer un
renault complète qui je le vois le puits
souvent ça va quand même se ressembler
plus j'y pense plus je l'aimé dit plus
que physique l'entré jeu capable de
l'interpréter le c'est rassurant je
trouve de méditer de de penser c'est
quelque chose mes pensées c'est quelque
chose que moi j'ai de contrôle fakty
j'essaie de contrôler tout ce que je
peux contrôler puis mèche pas quelqu'un
qui va être
sur le choc ou perturbés si jamais
quelque chose qui change j'ai vraiment
une capacité d'adaptation assez vite je
pense et c'est une de mes qualités
pilote dans six semaines de détente au
dessus d'un match un combo au sein des
ouais pis c'est pour le championnat du
monde est ce que c'est le conte ball à
date de ta carrière le plus important
défi nitive important puisque c'est pour
que ça représente quoi ce qu'on voulait
pour tous maintenant c'est 15 heures de
travail 15 en deux soirs de pleurs de st
des chèques de victoire de tous hurd à
faire des choix
qui m'ont amené le but c'est exactement
là où je voulais à être il agi suite et
je peux quasiment les frôler la
publication de toutes catégories
confondues lation de toute ma carrière
c'est le plus grand moment de ma vie à
ce moment là tu es mon entrée vers le
ring vers le championnat du monde avec
mon équipe avec je travaille depuis dix
ans que c'est notre rêve à tous le monde
on s'envole vivons ensemble c'est
quelque chose qui va être gros c'est
toute ma famille mes amis vont être les
ici à montréal ça va vraiment être gros
puis étais-je comme sidi j'imagine
tellement déjà à mon cou si le k
o
c'est moment lol je veux lui vie c'est
l'objectif ultime dans le fond le sait
la marche c'est tout la marche la plus
haute aux
quelque chose après ce oui il y ait si
peu unifiée parce qu'il yad'autres
championne du monde il ya quatre
champions du monde dans ma catégorie il
ya quatre compagnons peser moi c'est wbc
que je m'en bat yayi bfw bo wb à l'oeil
à une championne dans chacune des
catégories pas quand tu es au top ce
fait partie des quatre meilleurs qu'au
moment donné tu peux te regarde
conteneurs d'elle pour allait avoir deux
ceintures depuis un moment dans un monde
a ni unifiés pour avoir toutes les
ceintures ça c'est vraiment en
considération l'annoncé que
ça arrive beaucoup chez les hommes on en
voit quand même beaucoup mais c'est très
dur raconte envoyé cannelle ou albareil
avec lui me wade c'est vraiment les gars
qui sont capables d'aller battre toutes
les champions c'est ces grandes
chaussures à lacets le tournoi des
champions
c'est higuain
la grosse bourde d'argent dans ce quick
game le seco
tout le monde
[Rires]
l'a fait contre qui tu bosses une
exigence et qui comment elle s'appelle y
es sénia gomez c'est une fille c'est la
première championne du monde de cancun
qu'elle vient de cancun est championne
depuis 2018 ça va être sa cinquième
défense de son titre c'est la première
fois qu'elle va boxer en dehors du
mexique
c'est vraiment cool ce que
puis-je et élabore pour auxerre en
direct et avec ma coach de trois
semaines à boxer le 16 octobre on est
allé la voir boxer directement la banque
casino cancun fakty j'étais allé comme
espionner j'ai comme en mission
légale de le déstabiliser jusqu'au moyen
que fait la ligue 1 c'est sur ces ajouts
en tête un peu et tu imagines tu ton
adversaire avec qui compte quitte sur
vos box aux championnats du monde vient
de voir boxer chez vous assez payé un
billet d'avion l'hôtel tout pour venir
chez vous c'est sûr que ça joue dans la
tête c'est tellement drôle parce que son
promoteur puis l'annonceur et tout cas
qui m'ont vu là bas mais en fait monter
sur le ring ouais ben moi je pensais pas
plus jamais rien préparé j'avais pu me
posais plein de questions en espagnol
hola si
on s'est serré la main de regarder et
plus grande est quand même assez grande
ça va vraiment être un gros contre nos
adversaires du tableau la belle a fait
mais ça fait longtemps que les
professionnels a beaucoup d'expérience
je pense qu'on est rendu à 23 24 combats
professionnels
c'est quoi ça fuse c'est 18 et 19
victoires 5 défaites
deux combos nul puis je pense qu'à 8 ko
riches puis tout en béton têtu en
confiance absolue j'imagine que oui oui
ouais j'arrive le c'est sûr que tout
peut arriver dans votre box mais comme
vache folle au tarif bleu angola on
gagne je sais que je vais performer
j'étais une fille qui performent
beaucoup sur le stress on serait encore
plus que quand j'en ai pas j'ai besoin
de cette adrénaline le puis j'ai tout
les outils et j'ai toute l'équipe qui me
faut pour pouvoir arriver à la victoire
mais c'est à moi de livrer la
marchandise j'imagine qu'en ce moment à
plat on va pas entre eux mais un détail
d'un coup qu'il ya des espions mexicain
ici mais j'imagine que la forme en
attendant ton plan d'entraînement du
travail la faire vraiment spécifique à
cet adversaire le sait faire plein de
matches plus tout le travail puisse pas
souhaité garder aussi bien le voir jouer
on le répète on le répète le répète
c'est dans box est seul et les défauts
chez possible quand vous regardez les
combats de boxe voyez comme un qui est
fait pour voir ce coup de poing le deal
le bloquer mais ce que je pense que tout
ce que cette personne là en fait ça
devient tellement naturel tu y penses
même petit souvent le boxeur qui veulent
bloquer il s'est pas dit dans sa tête je
veux laver ma main parce que je vois qui
est en train de frapper ça fait même pas
tout de même pas le temps de réfléchir à
rien et dont encore le fait
automatiquement ça devient tout des
acquis que tu réfléchis même peau du
patient tout du coup de poing mais tu
étais même pas conscients que tu le
faisais ça le fait de le tuer c'est ce
qu'on répète on répète on répète on
répète pour avoir à moins réfléchir la
journée du combo parce que réfléchir
certes ralenti quand tu prend trop de
temps ça te fait des hésitations on veut
pas réfléchi show de la
memory fichu impôts petit vote fait
confiance à ton corps de bottes contre
une adversaire qui quand même pas le
plus grande que toi je me gêne c'est une
difficulté
vraiment ici une difficulté mais je suis
habitué quand même autant que dans ma
carrière amateur j'ai quand même tout le
temps dans les plus petites factions peu
nouveau pour moi de bosser contre
quelqu'un qui est plus grande mais mon
vrai je suis plus confortable de bosser
quand quelqu'un qui est plus grande que
quelqu'un qui est plus petit que moi à
mesure qu il combine plus comme une
pause plus grand que moi je suis 5e puis
elle est 5 pieds 6 ha ouais d'accord et
mes fans mes clips si vous êtes les deux
minuscules mais
moi je t'ai un petit peu plus musculaire
qui est mais les fêtes plus sur le long
la longueur des deux brosses à dents
jouer soit sage ou la porte
effectivement une stratégie pour le
rapport à ce coupé sa distance le ticket
d'être off avec elle deux pôles à
respecter c'est de rentrer les mais
aussi ce sujet les maillots comme ceux
qui aiment frappe si ce pas dangereux
mais il faut vraiment que tu deviennes
dit les avoir comme du béton le beau
paul a laissé faire ce qu'elle veut pas
la laisser s'installer pour la respecter
l'a fait reculer la mettre sur ses
talons la feb oxyde de reculons basque
est une porte que sur un jeu prévu sur
wii - lui servir le monde carte est plus
petit que leur lait qu'est ce qui est
bon c'est de boxer encore plus petit de
faire une cible encore plus petit que ça
devient plus difficile pour la personne
qui a des longs bruit ils sont trop
longs
ses hôtes et il ya encore des billets
j'imagine spawn un bruit et encore des
billets sur ticketmaster fait que ça
s'appelle la triple couronne parce qu'il
bord trois combats de championnat du
monde ce soir le don artur beterbiev que
l'est qui va défendre sa ceinture contre
markus blonde ça va vraiment être un
gros combat l'issue de combats et comme
vraiment je ne sais pas si c'est
pourquoi l'on sait
175 livres il va voir marié ève du caire
qui va boxer aussi pour as sidra voir sa
ceinture y bf qui va avoir moins que
passédat les détrôner y es sénia gomez
avec savoura va être une grosse soirée
de boxe c'est pas ça fait longtemps au
québec on ne peut pas une soirée de boxe
comme qui va avoir les mêmes avant je
faisais
ça va être sur les quais ce qui est le
fun c'est qu'arthur beterbiev j ai signé
avec top fringues c'est un des plus gros
promoteurs américains qui est avec yvon
michel ou si mon promoteur d'une co
promotion puis lui il ya rennes les
réseaux y aspirent dans le lac et nos
trois combats vont être sur les réseaux
la chaîne américaine est vraiment la
plus grosse chaîne au monde espionne fax
est vraiment belle visibilité moi aussi
c'est vraiment vraiment joyal et ça fait
longtemps je peux aller voir un match de
boxe la dernière fois
je n'aime pas ça remonte à 15 avec la
part des limites avec la pandémie au dos
le
défenseur
avec le avec la préparation que tout eu
j'imagine que
est ce qu'en fait est ce que dans ta pas
être la vision que ça se termine à ce
combat là dans le sens est ce que tu
après tu dis je vois finir ce combo
l'ofppt et après ce je penserai au next
step ou battait comme un peu de jeu un
mois ça s'arrête c'est vraiment monde
j'ai des objectifs à long terme mais
elles sont oubliées pour le moment je ne
pense pas si à court terme c est l est
cg même de plus en plus une vision
tunnel puis on dirait que je sais pas
pourquoi ce camp d'entraînement le
mais fait pas beaucoup de prise de
conscience sur moi-même
tranquille maintenant on apprend
beaucoup à se connaître au travers du
sport puis de la vie en général mais je
tenterai de prendre l'édition pour
m'améliorer encore plus si je réalise
que je passe énormément de temps sur mon
téléphone mais réseaux sociaux et puis
pendant ce temps là bas je mettais page
mais deux des fois j'aime lire je lis
pas parce que j'ai dit à mon téléphone à
côté je veux couper ce c'est vraiment
pour me recentrer sur moi même coupé mes
réseaux sociaux il ya une télévision
avec selon les distractions même si
c'est qu'on méchant n'est pas que je
néglige mes amis ma famille mais y
compris j'ai pas le temps moi de sortir
le vendredi soir ou d'aller visiter
telle personne déjà fait vraiment de
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour que le
jour j je me saoule je me dis pauvre
merde j'aurais donc dû est passé moins
de temps sur mon téléphone puis hmizi
répit les roues faire tel ou tel truc
dormir plus mon lieu d'avoir mon
téléphone d'un lieu jusqu'à 3 heures du
matin tifa que j'essaye vraiment de de
prendre conscience sur - puis de faire
les bons choix moitié de d'abord aucun
regret le 17 décembre qu'est ce que ce
que la boxe tu penses le vat avoir amené
le plus dans ta vie puis que tu vas
pouvoir traîner avec toi pour le reste
d'avis c'est quoi les apprentissages
parce que je suis sûr qu'ils en appelons
à essayer de la confiance en moi
certains
des gens avec qui je vais avoir un
amitié td des amis qui sont devenus
comme des sorts le dans ma vie les gens
c'est des amis des vrais amis j'en ai
peu de temps mais surtout une amie sarah
cali c'est une fille qui ont été sur
l'équipe nationale ensemble vient même
dans mon coin quand je boxe ça on est
vraiment comme des sorts puisque c'est
quelque chose que la boxe va m'avoir
apporté mais ça va être une amie pour la
vie et aussi
parce que dans la vie moi je suis
désorganisé sous le saviez à quel point
je suis une personne désorganisé
c'est le ménage la vaisselle m'a chambré
par une pile de linge touche pas
organisé pendant toutes mes dents la
boxe je suis très très difficile mais
j'ai mon agenda taylor jean-pierre tel
truc je vais manger telle affaire fait
que je pense que ça m'a aidé à
m'organiser dans les autres faire de ma
vie thème apprendre à avoir une oreille
il a respecté parce que je suis vraiment
et
ça aide d'avoir l équipe le kick tamines
jusqu'ici par les catalans ont envoyé
ces structures mais
la bourse et
ses besoins parce que quand j'ai
commencé à boxer mettons et jeter ou
secondaire puis j'étais quand même assez
être vertige avait pas tant d'amis mais
j'étais timide
déjà je vivais des affaires aussi côté
familial qui était j'ai dû me
débrouiller à ces jeunes dans la vie
aimait tant puis la boxe ça m'a apporté
un sentiment d'appartenance
c'est quand j'arrive au jeune homme
c'est comme une famille et des gens qui
s'occupaient de moi outil qui était très
paternel mettant mon premier coach de
moyens peu comme un père fx avait
vraiment fait du bien pipe plus je
m'améliorais dans la boxe plus je
m'améliorais dans la vie mais ashton
décrochage scolaire puis tout ne siéger
j'ai vraiment j'ai fini mon cerveau
derrière 5 j'avais 21 ans et j'y
retourne à l'école j'allais refaire mon
compte en anglais c'est tout par rapport
à la boxe et des amis que j'ai fait dans
la boxe qui m'ont incitée kim félicite
importe tant pis ah ouais vient habiter
chez nous à montréal c'est comme ça de
ma vie j'étais venait buter deux à
montréal du pendant que je faisais mon
secondaire 5 puis mes amis m'ont
beaucoup aidé c'est tout des amis que
j'ai rencontrés dans la boxe accès j'ai
eu un bon cirque des bonnes influences
puissent-ils toute la boxe qui
m'apportait
ce1 à
trouver une appartenance c'est vraiment
une des choses principales tuer mais je
vais juste penser
comme moi je vais partir qu'on le
mariage c'est moi la natation ça a été
ça a été la partenaire c'est quand le
lot true études accomplies dans quelque
chose paiement cip dans quelque chose
puis le monde le monde est en cours est
réputé titre en comptant sur la même
passion ouais exact exacte tout ensemble
vous vous élevez puis attendez qu'ils
élevaient à l'intérieur de cette affaire
là bas ça permet de sentir mieux puis
d'être plus à l'aise à l'extérieur de ce
film et puis même les hommes c'est des
groupes comme comme l'aider
selon marc les geeks qui joue à donjons
dragons mettons le petit bain christ un
sentiment d'appartenance part et ils
sont une gaine qui ont étudié des amis
ton intérêt comment es-tu tellement
c'est dans ce même s'il s'émancipe et
dans un monde imaginaire ça peut
paraître fou mais dans le fond ce pas
plus imaginaires que la natation le thé
dansant sous ce qui est juste quelque
chose avec des 5 1 et celle de de
performances pures d'erreurs mais s'est
trouvé un sentiment d'appartenance
points pour les hawks est tellement
important rien mais l'important c'est de
croire sir à quelqu'un qui rêve de
devenir artiste mais vas-y et c'est une
grande décision pluton vous risquez d'en
vie pour essayer de réussir thiam et on
on m'avait dit un jour kim va boxer au
centre bell pour un championnat du monde
c'est quand j'avais 13 ans 14 a su foot
ou ailier même pas de filles qui bloque
comme tu penses pas sûr mais contrée ma
mission le c'est d'encourager les jeunes
des d'inspirer les jeunes a foncé dans
la vie peu importe la soirée 15 1 2 lors
de la danse nous importe le sport que tu
sois un homme une femme jeune vieux
n'importe quoi comme tu dis avoir un
sentiment d'appartenance dans quelque
chose mais brune patients d'avoir un
sillon patients ce qui fait tiquer tuque
les petits c'est une risotto vie dans le
temps de secondaire quant aux sports est
tout petit soupir donc je regarde notre
gang puis je regarde
le monde avec on allait à l'école contre
les titans à ce moment le logo du monde
chipotons devenus des des belles
personnes à majorité du monde c'est
parce que son son pot tombé d'entrée
dans toutes sortes de problèmes non plus
au drake laisse pas au juste le fait
d'avoir une passion ça de garde un plus
droit chemin une certaine manière parce
qu'ils étaient quelque chose qui est une
raison de lever des quelque chose que tu
peux t'améliorer de quelque chose que tu
veux faire puis qui que tu veux pas non
plus bousiller attestant leur jeu des
longs secondaire deux parties de temps
en temps mais tirons des sommes tout
sage pour des ados parce qu'il y avait
la tentation qui disait la priorité
c'est je peux pas aller
je dormais pas la nuit où c'est facile
de mesurer que tu es offre attention
notre coach avec un chrono pouvait
savoir c'est comme
un chrono une fois si on n'avait pas eu
ce jour-là on saura jamais mais dont la
vie rédéné quoi mais c'est clair que ça
ça ça de forge une personne puis ça te
fait devenir une meilleure personne ça
c'est sûr et ça c'est sûr
là-dessus je n'entends parler puis te te
tue excuses de penser donner des
conférences parce que là tu te situes tu
raconte que tu étais décrochage scolaire
puis ça te ramener la poursuite des
thérapies tout ce que tu dis depuis
tantôt je trouve ça vraiment fascinante
je trouve que c'est un message qui est
ultra pertinent surtout entendre pour
des pour des jeunes et y donner des
conférences parler de ton parcours c'est
quelque chose que tu fais quelque chose
que tu sais pas quelque chose que je
fais encore gelé fait une fois j'avais
été
une de mes amies un travail dans une
école secondaire c'est l'école où
j'allais et
puis j'étais fan conférence le puis j'ai
vraiment vu les jeunes avaient apprécié
et interagir avec eux opposés les
questions montrer mon parcours puis mon
parcours était vraiment la moitié
peut-être douche lui en ce moment là que
je pense c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais vraiment faire à la suite
comme le je veux être champion du monde
mais là je suis apprécié c'est quelque
chose que j'aimerais aller jaser avec
les jeunes parce que je trouve la gdc
tellement importante et c'est là relève
c'est eux qui vont prendre les décisions
de plus nos futures décisions ça va et
et aux autres que j'aimerais beaucoup
aller josé avec eux montré mon parcours
puis c'est des fois voir une petite
fille ce qui peut te fait penser à ce
que tu étais pu dire ce que tu aurais
mis tout à te faire dire
trouve que c'est tellement important
pitté être certaines personnes dans
notre vie chez peau si vous avez
rencontré quelqu'un qui vous a déjà dit
une parole ou quelque chose qui reste
restant times allait peut-être même
changé le le coc du reste de ta vie de
tout et on a tout le monde dans même je
pense qu'on croise le chemin des profs
c'est moi je pense à deux ou trois mais
ton prof que je
vais me rappeler toute ma vie mon markit
qui ont forgé la personne que je suis un
axe important de donner des personnes
comme ceux dont une femme petite
différence dans la vie des jeunes des
fois c'est con parce que c'est une
phrase dite amener des deux mois j'ai
des exemples de deux personnes qui ont
même pas des personnes que jugé
extrêmement
inspirant tu le mets juste a amené il ya
une phrase qui m'est revenue puis que je
pense souvent que je fais comme ça ça
guide certaines de mes décisions pour
cette personne-là kaka le dit
quand ils
viennent chanter ces normes énoncées ses
confrères le au contraire mais comme ça
ne sais ce que ça fait chaque nom pareil
on bien plus de porte et qu'on le pense
je suis là seulement servi je suis allé
là une couple d'années après que j'avais
fait occupation double je suis je me
souhaite inviter à un école pour donner
une conférence sur besbre une conférence
à personne atelier de création taira pas
j'ai créé décombres un combat avant
d'aller à occupation demain et je suis
allé là puis les jeunes est assis devant
moi parce que j'ai fait dans le fond
c'est que j'avais noté une coupe
d'affaires
une coupe de questions dans le fond il
fallait que les jeunes répondent à ces
questions là où on me donne des idées tu
me ton ça me prend un objet magique
plustek comme une carotte qui inquiète
infinie de ses films dont tu crois que
la carotte pilote assure le tabou
cheville est encore
le le tg plein de questions comme ce
plat au final à fond et j'avais toutes
leurs questions puis moi j'étais dans ma
tête j'avais déjà
une planification d'un compte que je
voulais leur raconter sauf que
j'utilisais dans le fond les réponses à
leurs questions pour raconter ce conclu
mais avec leurs idées puis un jeu
d'enfant en attendant suscitait leur
histoire comme si jeune et
d'exotisme voix et qui trompait toute la
bref d'être que c'était vraiment le fun
je participe cet été
je donne un jeune un coup de main à un
ami une pizzeria dans le bas du fleuve
puis
un couple est venu manger le pim ont
reconnu parce que je suis était serveur
est en fait et dit on était prof à telle
école card est venu puis on était nous
autres on était en arrière plus moi je
le reconnaissais pas parce qu'ils savent
taper longtemps puis mais disent les
jeunes en ont parlé littéralement
pendant toute l'année scolaire l'année
d'après sont rentrés dans leur cour puis
ont dit à leurs profs qui continue d'en
parler après un été complet de ce compte
là comment il avait trouvé ça une seule
salle il avait marre salée j'avais
marqué complètement mouche sortie de
l'attaquant mais on a eu un good times
téléphone si les jeunes filles en ont
parlé pendant deux
2 portes et donc on
tue peut-être y en a un en gagne quoi
faire crimes des comptes c'est le fun
tilly sur la littérature mais oui j'ai
envie de le faire taxer ceux qui veulent
apporter le groupe de joueurs il ya une
madame à mes écrits amedick aimé
est ce que ça me dérangerait de répondre
à une ou deux questions mam actifs et
comme aux primaires a fait sa
communication orale sur toi
ça arrive de plus en plus comme sa
communication écrite sa communication
aura sa production écrite ils font sur -
le hive urgence envoie une petite photo
ou un père de famille mais 10 km et je
trouvais ce bout de temps voyez cette
photo de ma fille adore avec ta photo à
côté de son lit
recherche avait les larmes qui ne
coulent 11d comme ses petites filles là
avant d'aller se coucher à regarde ma
photo c'est comme
j'ai passé six ans comme son héros son
petit modèle medef pour lequel qu'un ça
te donne tu as envie de prendre les
bonnes décisions dans vivre ça te donne
tu as envie de réussir ou d'être une
bonne personne puis de montrer l'exemple
je pense qu'il m'a prêté en motivation
moi j'ai écouté bois 2 puis mettez pas
ce truc c'est que ça fait c'est parce
que tu aimes la vie est si je pense que
ça te fait découvrir a vraiment beaucoup
de monde s'épie je me suis aussi quand
est-elle les axes où le sport je te
connaissais avant sur mes mais
effectivement pour la grande salle et
fait monsieur madame tout le monde qui
devient plus une personnalité publique à
ce moment puis est ce que c'est quelque
chose que je sais qu'il a après tu
penses pas au métier est ce qui est des
plus dans le public plus d'un mais
depuis plus est quelqu'un qui tique et
kike que c'est portela d'inspirer le
monde quelque chose que qui t'intéresse
maintenant sur le long terme oui c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse
mais c'est big brother gelé vraiment en
fait à la base j'avais un peu
comme si
c'était les gens qui votaient ce avec
qu'on habitait j'aurais peut-être cette
plus ça
parce que le vrai big brother en fait
les personnes sont éliminés regarde pas
les émissions savons une autre maison
puis comme il voit pas que c'est ce
qu'ils peuvent tout changer dès qu'on
leur a menti mais en même temps ce par
ses seuls jeux de mentir de travail est
d'aller trouver des façons de faire qui
sont pas toujours correctes monsieur
madame tout le monde mais c'est un jeu
ouais j'ai peut-être pas toujours été
très
correct assume mais j'ai vraiment voulu
embarquer là-dedans premier justement
pour me faire connaître un peu plus de
monsieur madame tout le monde parce que
la boxe est un business il faut vendre
des tickets temps un petit faut que les
gens soient intéressés à venir te voir
et je le ferai connaître la boxe
féminine puis c'était vraiment ça mon
objectif puis en plus des drames ont
cédé sous pour pouvoir investir dans ma
carrière parce que 50 de mon cher une
carrière de boxe c'est ce que j'ai fait
mais si je pense que ça l'est vraiment
fonctionné comme vraiment une vague
négative
une semaine deux semaines à ma sortie
mais après si ça c'est vraiment une
semaine deux semaines je te garantis
sait pas trop
quand même car pendant un bon petit bout
mais ce test est mitigé
j'ai tellement trouvé ça dur parce que
j'étais tellement habitué des mosquées
poussent ces combos positif l'infirmière
et le pâté milka les documents
nécessaires et céder la pandémie si tu
es toujours bobobo le steak comme jeter
une hypocrite une si je te jure je
m'habille mal j'ai des trous des jing
j'arrive dans le fond c'est tout sorte
d'enfer mais shell je lisais sopi city
de bouc mentir à temps même en disant
moi ça me fait rien les eaux je m'en
fous dans ton petit coeur en dedans toît
craque un peu je suis petit c'est soit
que des missions mêmes savent eux la
loupe ou 6 heures un aspect avec des
personnalités
ces jeux le monsieur plus ces faussetés
qu'on leur souffrance one en bas aussi
pas longtemps après qu'il soit sorti ou
73 ghz en jeu c'est tout un métier et
je me souviens qu est il
il disait thi kim kim d'art maison
c'était un petit clown
téléphonie tettey était drôle d'été film
tu étais tous ceux qui ont moins vu son
raté mais on n'a pas vu cependant de
dégager regardé l'émission chemin alors
commencé à jeûner femme est en jeu j'ai
quelque chose le contexte n'était pas
surtout parce maison par maison là comme
une différence y ont jeté le clown j'ai
rien chanter je n'y étais 116 je pense
pour ce que je vais pas mettre chénier
êtes tout à fait des enfants pour
rapport j'ai je faisais des acrostiches
à tout le monde à genthod mots qu'ils
savaient pas son jeu mais pour répéter
souffre mais comme tout suspense peut
pas mettre dans des villes tous les
jours pas question d'envoyer mes moments
un peu plus de jeu que le rap est
équitable camille qui parlait tout ainsi
qu'un
jeu transparent terme avec 2 mai 7e
permis comme tu disais de steam et on a
enfin marqué en train de monter tout
l'entourage qui est au biberon doute est
permis d'avoir d'être aussi bien entouré
aujourd'hui ou ouais ouais ouais
vraiment je suis bien entouré j'ai du
bon monde autour d'un mot tout le monde
est bien géré les situations étaient
aujourd'hui je suis je parle encore
beaucoup avec jean thomas françois
il était alors mon dernier combat
c'est une expérience humaine inoubliable
personne d'autre que ce que tu l'as fait
qu'ils savent de quoi tu parles un
exemple assez d'être enfermés 93 jours
semblent aller dans ce sens ton
téléphone à rien de vivre son deuil
devant tout le monde québec parce que
mon grand père décédé pendant que telle
à bord
cette erreur quelqu'un qui tellement
dans type lean dans mes combats taylor
je me laisserais telle affaire je
m'avoue jumelage de manger tes le truc
piloter
avec cette personne blood qui ronfle
autres qui parlent de deux toilettes
pour 15 personnes dites vous ça fait 15
ans j'avais tout seul dans mon petit
trou et demi pour baby lust épisode tout
même réussi à garder une routine
d'entraînement pour super selon des
standards ou ce gamin owen avec françois
tu es juste un athlète ou
symboliques quelque chose tu te défonces
lançaient des défis bons freins
qu'aujourd'hui on monte on descend les
marches pendant 30 minutes on faisait f1
qu'aujourd'hui on fait dix prix d'une
minute puis telle affaire aujourd'hui on
fait trois heures de cardio confère un
an et de course world elliptique 1 heure
de vélo québec comme tout ce qui est des
fous le monde ne nous regardez la
jeunesse
il n'est joué de la guitare méchante
épisode on était sur nous et nous
encourager mon faisait nos trois heures
après ce groupe on va faire et on va
manger bien pendant une semaine tu es
tout le monde mais guéri à big brother
parce qu'ils les mangent et bien on dit
et c'est quand même une gamme positive
pour de vrai mais si je vais retourner a
pu me parla -
d'avant odile ce serait mon conseil
numéro ce serait arrête jamais de
t'entraîner parce que la seconde j'ai
arrêté de m'entraîner c'est là que
mentalement je commençais à broyer de la
com - vraiment bien faire et laisser
déranger par des affaires qui
habituellement me dérangerait pas
pantoute le td c'est vraiment quand j'ai
arrêté de m'entraîner puis je sais
exactement ses camps dans l'émission
puis je le vois tu ce
débat lancé dans
ce cas où cela mais le tir et à liste
seraient liées au ccd peau c'est un
véritable désarroi les propos seraient
jamais dit comme tu te reconnais même
plus des fois des fois ça me fait super
nous autres on n'a pas quand même
souvent le sur le podcast de sommer sa
mort fait seuil harkis et y en avait
quand même un bon début de journée ici
pis moi j'avais j'avais d'autres
affaires à faire en arrivant à l'appart
puis mon horaire de quand même temps
puis j'avais j'avais un show le soir
fait que j'ai comme limité dans le temps
qu'il fallait choisir j'étais comme un
peu overwhelmed eu de tout les enfants
j'avais à faire puis le jeu d'aller
courir puis en revenant il y avait plus
rien qui est dérangeant george ii comme
arme on aura et il faut que je fasse ce
soir j'aurais pas dans le far le faire
demain matin ferme le dossier s'est fait
le même site et arrêter d'être compliqué
en tout cas tu es toi là-bas des gestes
clairs et complètement il l'oeil plus
rien qui peut me diras tu reviens dans
le job mettons le tout rien d'une heure
de sport des tibias qu'il n'y a rien qui
peut déranger ses méthodes son du djembé
dans le trafic juste l'expérience dans
ton genre dans le trafic est
complètement différente quand tu viens
de faire du sport ou pour quelqu'un qui
roule lentement là avant toi tu voles
suivent un peignoir
sauget pas drôle ça va sans dire que
c'était comme tu viennes par pas journée
de travail peu dans le trafic de survie
un petit empan tabarnak parce qu'ils
n'ont pas c'est quand tu viens de perdre
du poids ça fait jamais sur cv fait que
fait non non ce pilot d'affaires aussi
que je voulais dire par rapport aux
commentaires négatifs pour reprendre les
mots de mon ami n'entend roi il dit le
monde qui se mettent à chialer ces
réseaux sociaux puis quitte en voie de
la haine ces réseaux sociaux qui m'ont
mourir ya pas grave on s'ennuie
[Musique]
mais la santé le monde qui prennent le
temps d'envoyer de la marque serrée
sociaux pour quelque chose qui ont vu
qu'ils m'aiment pas une me régis
représentation de toi sion qu'il faut
pas quitter
l'expression est vraiment intense mais
ce que ça veut dire si on sait encore
comment ces questions dans mon entourage
tout de suite et j'ai été parler à
quelqu'un souhaitait rapidement bruit de
la marde non jamais tout est déjà donc
l'on réalisé personne n'avait jamais
fait sur saône suis un petit vaisseau si
j'ai perdu un enfant ce ticket c'est lé
genre de groupe femmes pays du big band
impulsé seyec sur le titre tu vois les
cinquante personnes qu'ils font mal au
québec depuis l'été ils font du bruit le
jouer
quand j'ai sorti de big bear pascal remy
et ce nouveau processus d'appel je
voyais maman qui répondait à temps si le
cliché kanak et non ma fille est pas
comme ce pas on la voulait bien faire
les schtroumpfs mais le topo le site et
nourrissent demande le vote nourrir ce
titre getting out listings au puy foot
et lisa moins possible le matin du bord
de mon père qui allait protéger le monde
y est ça devient salle vient d'une
lourdeur infini pour ce monde là aussi
le oui
fait la même chose il fallut cappart
deux semaines dans le sud après au
départ ce qui était brûlée
c'est distincts que pareil
bain j'imagine que je sais qu est-ce qu
on parce que la forte laisser aller
bientôt que trouvera-t-on deuxième
entraînement je suis ici qu'est ce qu'on
souhaite dans le petit l'immédiat mais
les gens qui veulent suivre qui veulent
aller voir ton sur ton jetons j'adore
ton spectacle allez voir qu'on peut
rêver à les ventes on combat sembel
sultan de plus gai tout ce que tu veux
plus qu'il n'aime voir boxer le 17
décembre c'est un beau cadeau de noël à
offrir à vos proches des beaux billets
de boxe avait une grosse soirée
mon premier championnat du monde
j'aimerais seule vie avec toutes les
québécois c'est qu'on gagne son ensemble
parce que les québécois me soutiennent
vraiment beaucoup depuis les dernières
années
ça va être un grand moment factuel et
sur ticketmaster et encore des bons
billets ça port assez vite ça s'appelle
la triple couronne va avoir trois
combats de championnat du monde ce soir
le aller acheter vos billets offerts un
bain du bruit puis envoyé - beaucoup
d'énergie parce que je maintenant aux
besoins qu'une buvette ou tu la prends
très très cool puis le monde serait
personnellement ou serait g20 twitter qu
clavel et où simon instagram kim klavel
facebook professionnel quelqu'un qu'il
avait trop m'appelle kéké que toujours à
cause de mon premier coach c'est
l'enfant clavel s'inscrire avec 1,6 mais
lui il crée toujours avec un beau jeune
et michel jestin cdu tard on sait plus
boire un coup avec quel hôtel
tout le monde s'est mis à m'appeler
cliquer jusqu'à pas que j'aillais
l aéro pas parce que c'était mon premier
voyage international jallet boxer en
tunisie puis avait mis un corps pour mon
inscription puis aux douanes j'ai failli
passer parce que c'est comme si mon
bateau mais c'est trop dans le monde
appelait déjà qu'ils infectent pour ce
qu'on appelle
la gaule merci beaucoup puis le plus
grand des succès les passions les gars
faut rester sage
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur l'eau pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois sans
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
mois en laisse par mois et vous avez les
pas de carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis à leurs
côtés les podcasts puisse avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous à l'étude de
la dynamique entre les amys tout le
temps avons une avance sur l'étude joe
braun avance les gens autour de toi mais
avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le chèque le podcast unis
voulu nous en dire davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on vend jose ont
battu les nicole non nicolas hulot
maintenant comme un fils travaille la
place travot détaillé le mets en jason
par la conversion convient d'avoir mais
ce si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous